here in the occupied West Bank this un
clinic at El Amari refugee camp near
Ramallah is closed it's the third day
workers have gone on strike to demand
better salaries at the un's relief and
works agency
ownerwa was mandated by the un's general
assembly to provide humanitarian
assistance and protection to Palestinian
refugees expelled from their homes
during what they called the nakba or
catastrophe in 1948.
Tema motor is one Refugee who usually
receives treatment at this Center but
not today
of course the agency was much better
before their withdrawing the services
have diminished over time the agency
provides services for nearly 6 million
Palestinian refugees less than 900 000
of them live in the West Bank
for them education and health are the
most important services
commissioner General says the agency is
underfunded on Tuesday he appealed for
1.6 billion dollars for 2023 to cover
needs in countries hosting Palestinian
refugees donors financial support for
the agency has been declining over
recent years but
say it can afford salary increases for
its local workers
the head of the workers union says the
agency is using the financial crisis as
an excuse to avoid discussing pay raises
in 1989 overall budget was 6.5 million
now 30 years later the budget is still
6.5 million no adjustment has been made
to the value over the past years
owner was says salaries have increased
regularly and urged the union to end the
strike
now the unrest priority for this year is
to keep providing services to employees
and keep paying salaries this way we can
survive
in the besieged Gaza Strip employees are
holding a partial strike to support
their colleagues in the West Bank
officially honor was mandate is valid
until a just and Lasting solution to the
plight of refugees is reached but with
their numbers increasing donors spending
their money elsewhere and a lack of a
political solution that goal is looking
increasingly distant
foreign